I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi there! Today we're going to talk about manager and salesman. We have a huge episode. It really is. It is season 6, episode 16, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Mark Webb. Hit us with a summary, lady. Here it is. Saber CEO, Jo Bennett visits Dunder Mifflin Scranton. She brings her two great Danes, her autobiography, and a lot
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。大家好！嗨！今天我们要谈的是经理与推销员。我们有一集内容丰富的大制作。确实如此。这是第六季第十六集，由明迪·卡林编剧，马克·韦布导演。来个总结吧，女士。就是这样。萨博首席执行官乔·贝内特造访邓德米夫林斯堪顿分公司。她带来了她的一对大丹犬、她的自传和许多
of new policies. When she discovers that Michael and Jim are co-managers, she tells them there can only be one manager and they have until the end of the day to decide who will be a salesperson and who will stay on as manager. Meanwhile, Andy is handing out Valentine's cards to everyone in the office, which sparks confusion as to where his affections truly lie. I am telling you, watching Andy and Erin is making me crazy. I just want one of them to just say, I like you. I know, but they have the thing where the neither one of them will ask the other one out. It's making me crazy. It's very sweet. It is sweet, but it's making me crazy.
新政策。当她发现迈克尔和吉姆是联席经理时，她告诉他们只能有一个经理，他们必须在今天结束前决定谁将成为销售员，谁将继续担任经理。与此同时，安迪正在给办公室里的每个人分发情人节卡片，这引发了人们对他真正心仪何人的困惑。我跟你说，看安迪和艾琳的互动让我快疯了。我只想让他们其中一个人说一句“我喜欢你”。我知道，但他们就是那种谁也不肯开口约对方的类型。这让我快疯了。这很甜蜜。确实很甜，但它让我快疯了。
Fast fact number one, Kathy Bates is Jo Bennett. Kathy flipping Bates. Now I know she was on last week's episode, but it was via a computer screen. Here she is, live in person. Walking right next to us, talking to us. You know, Kathy Bates is one of just a few actors who have been nominated for the triple crown of acting. That means that she has been nominated for a Tony for her work on the stage and Academy Award for film and Emmy for television. By the way, she has won an Academy Award, two Golden Globes, two SAG Awards and two Emmy Awards. Her nominations for awards were so many that I actually got confused. I couldn't even
第一条冷知识，凯西·贝茨饰演乔·贝内特。活生生的凯西·贝茨。我知道她上周的剧集里就出现过了，但那是通过电脑屏幕。现在她来了，活生生地出现在现场。从我们身边走过，跟我们说话。你知道吗，凯西·贝茨是极少数获得表演大满贯提名的演员之一。这意味着她曾因舞台表演获得托尼奖提名，因电影获得奥斯卡奖提名，因电视获得艾美奖提名。顺便说一句，她曾赢得过一座奥斯卡奖、两个金球奖、两个演员工会奖和两个艾美奖。她的奖项提名实在是太多了，以至于我都有点搞混了。我甚至无法
track them all. It's so many. Yeah, so you guys, we were a little nervous. I mean, this acting legend came in to our job. We got a lot of mail, Angela, asking what was our reaction to having Kathy Bates. I mean, I think you just heard it. We were so excited, but I was really nervous. I was intimidated. Yeah, but not by anything other than just her presence, because she's very lovely. You know, she was so nice to everyone. Oh my gosh. Yes, she's super down to earth and kind. Yeah. But her legacy that followed her into the room was massive. Yes, she had this quiet power as she walked in the room. I was so nervous to say anything to her. You know, my hair
追踪所有的提名。实在是太多了。是的，所以大家当时都有点紧张。我是说，这位表演传奇来到了我们工作的剧组。安吉拉，我们收到了很多邮件，问我们对见到凯西·贝茨有什么反应。我是说，我想你们刚也听到了。我们非常兴奋，但我真的很紧张。我被镇住了。是的，但并不是因为别的，仅仅是因为她的存在感，因为她非常可爱。你知道的，她对每个人都很好。噢天哪。是的，她超级脚踏实地而且善良。是的。但她带进房间的传奇光环是巨大的。是的，她走进房间时自带一种安静的气场。我紧张得跟她说什么都不敢。你知道的，我的发型
colorist of over 20 years, Robert Hickland. I love this man. He told me once that he also colored Kathy Bates's hair once. What? This was before Kathy was on our show. He said, oh, I don't know how she came up, but he was like, I colored her hair once. And when he told me that I was floored and now here she was, she had come in and I remember that I was sitting at the reception desk and it was like, I wanted to be like, my hairdresser did your hair once. No way. You have to suppress, suppress. Yes, yes. But I was like, moment of connection. I have something in common with you. Same man has colored our hair. That is what I
师，合作了二十多年的罗伯特·希克兰。我爱这个人。他曾告诉我，他也给凯西·贝茨染过一次头发。什么？这是在凯西出演我们的节目之前。他说，哦，我不知道怎么说起的，但他就随口说，我给她染过一次头发。当他告诉我这件事时，我惊呆了，现在她居然来了，我记得我当时坐在前台，那种感觉就像，我很想说，“我的发型师给你染过头发。”不行。你得克制，克制。对，对。但我就在想，这是一个交集的时刻。我和你有什么共同点。同一个人给我们的头发染过色。这就是我
was so nervous and I had to like make sure I didn't do that. I do think that like eventually by day three, I did tell her that tidbit and it was, you know, the response you would expect, which was, oh. Anyway, Kathy Bates was on Anderson when Anderson Cooper had his own talk show and she talked about being on the office and I thought we could give it a listen. How was it like working with a comedy ensemble versus the cast on Harry's Law? Well, I was going off Steve Carell, you know, and actually I had worked with Rainn Wilson. I actually cast him when I was directing an episode of Six Feet Under. Oh, really? Yeah. Way, way back. Of
当时紧张的地方，我必须确保自己没有说漏嘴。我觉得到了第三天，我确实把这个小八卦告诉了她，而她的反应正如你所料，就是“哦”。不管怎样，凯西·贝茨曾上过安德森·库珀自己的脱口秀节目《安德森》，她在节目中谈到了出演《办公室》的经历，我想我们可以听听看。与《律政俏律师》剧组相比，和喜剧演员班底合作是什么感觉？嗯，我是跟着史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的节奏来的，实际上我以前跟雷恩·威尔逊合作过。当我导演《六尺之下》的一集时，其实是我选角选中了他。哦，真的吗？对。很早很早以前。
course. He was great on Six Feet Under. Oh, yeah. He was terrific and so it's been wonderful to watch him on the office, just knock it out of the ballpark all the time. But it was great to work with Steve Carell and I loved working with the two great Danes. That was a lot of fun. So I didn't know this until I saw this clip. She has actually directed a ton of television, including five episodes of Six Feet Under. And like she said, she directed Rainn Wilson. So I reached out to Rainn. You did? Yeah. And he described the experience as a quote double whammy. He said, I got a major role on one of the deepest, most respected
当然。他在《六尺之下》里演得很棒。哦，是的。他棒极了，所以看着他在《办公室》里一直表现得那么惊艳，真是太棒了。但能和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作真的很棒，而且我很喜欢跟那两只大丹犬合作。那真的超级有趣。所以在看到这个片段之前我并不知道这件事。她其实导演过大量的电视剧，包括《六尺之下》的五集。就像她说的，她导演过雷恩·威尔逊。所以我联系了雷恩。你联系了？对。他把这次经历形容为“双重打击”。他说，我在一部最深刻、最受尊敬的
TV shows going on. It was on HBO, no less. And at the same time, I was being directed by an Oscar winner. He said it was a dream come true that she was an excellent director. He said they rehearsed a lot and she gave great notes, which of course wasn't surprising. But he said he was definitely quite intimidated, which made him act very formal and somewhat awkward around her. Wait, more awkward than usual for Rainn? Exactly. But he said this was actually perfect for the character he was playing. Oh, right. But the very first episode that he did of Six Feet Under was directed by Kathy Bates. So she was a big
电视剧里拿到了一个重要角色。而且这可是HBO出品的剧集。与此同时，我还在一位奥斯卡奖得主的导演手下拍戏。他说这简直梦想成真，而且她是一位极其优秀的导演。他说他们排练了很多次，她给出了很好的意见，这当然不足为奇。但他坦言自己确实非常紧张，这导致他在她面前显得格外拘谨甚至有些尴尬。等等，比雷恩平时还要尴尬？没错。但他说这其实非常符合他当时扮演角色的特质。哦，对的。雷恩参演的《六尺之下》的第一集就是由凯西·贝茨执导的。所以她在挑选他出演那个对他而言至关重要的
part of picking him for that role that became a major recurring role for him. Wow. So she was a pivotal person in his life. Yeah. In his career. Yes. That is so cool. Well, fast fact number two, Kathy mentioned on Anderson the Great Danes. I remember the Great Danes. How could we forget the Great Danes? Two small like ponies were on set with us. Yes. And on set with us a lot. Randy Cordray said that we once again went to Bob Dunn's Animal Services and their head trainer Denise Sanders came through for us. The dog's names were Gabby and Guinness. He said they were truly majestic, gorgeous, and very well disciplined. I remember
常驻角色上发挥了很大作用。哇。所以她是他生命中的一个关键人物。是的。对他的职业生涯来说也是。没错。太酷了。好了，第二条冷知识，凯西在安德森的节目里提到了大丹犬。我还记得大丹犬。我们怎么可能忘得了大丹犬呢？两匹小马一样的狗狗和我们一起在片场。是的。而且大部分时间都在片场陪着我们。兰迪·科德雷说，我们再次找到了鲍勃··邓恩动物服务公司，他们的首席训练师丹妮丝·桑德斯为我们提供了大力帮助。狗狗的名字叫加比和吉尼斯。他说它们真的雄伟、漂亮而且纪律严明。我记得
that. They were really amazing. Incidentally, David Denman had a Great Dane, who I spent quite a bit of time with. And I remember this thing where David Denman told me that Great Danes are great apartment dogs. How so? He said they're just really, really chill and they actually don't need a lot of exercise. That a lot of smaller dogs are far more active. They need to go out. They need walking. But Great Danes are kind of like just big loungers. That makes sense. You know, my little Chihuahua mixes, they get what we call the zoomies. Yes. Where they zoom around and run and run and run in a circle. Maggie is a large dog. She's
那个。它们真的很棒。顺便说一句，大卫·丹曼曾养过一只大丹犬，我和它相处了挺长时间。我记得大卫·丹曼跟我说过大丹犬是非常棒的公寓宠物。怎么说？他说它们真的非常非常冷静，实际上并不需要太多运动。很多小型犬其实要活跃得多。它们需要出门。需要遛弯。但大丹犬基本上就是那种大型的“沙发土豆”。这倒说得通。你知道的，我的小吉娃娃混血犬，它们会经历我们所说的“疯狂冲刺”。是的。就是它们会绕着圈子飞奔、狂奔、狂奔。玛吉是一只大型犬。她是
a shepherd mix. That's Jenna's dog. It's like eight times the size of my dog. And Maggie also gets the zoomies. She does. I've seen her. And it's like get out of the way. Oh yeah, she'll take you down. I wanted to know a little bit more about this to make sure that this, you know, anecdote from David Denman that I remembered all these years was true. And yes, according to City Dogs Life, Great Danes make great apartment dogs. But they had a list of three things that you might want to consider if you are going to put a Great Danes in a small apartment. And they are, number one, just simply the great amount of space that the
一只牧羊犬混血。那是詹娜的狗。体型大概是我家狗的八倍。而且玛吉也会疯狂冲刺。她确实会。我见过她那样。那感觉就像是快闪开。哦对，她会把你撞倒。我想多了解一点这方面的信息，以确保大卫·丹曼多年前告诉我的这个趣事是真的。是的，根据《城市狗狗生活》网站的说法，大丹犬确实是极好的公寓宠物。但他们列出了三件你在把大丹犬养在小公寓里时可能需要考虑的事。它们是：第一，狗狗会占用的空间非常大，甚至在走廊里站着也是如此。我的意思是，说得对。第二，大丹犬可能会用它们又长又粗的尾巴不小心撞倒相框、花瓶和其他家具。对。
dog will take up, even standing in a hallway. I mean, good point. Number two, the potential for a Great Danes to accidentally knock over pictures, vases, and other furnishings with their long, powerful tails. Yes. Yes. And three, the loudness of their bark might bother your neighbors. But in terms of being chill, they're great in an apartment. So when we watched this episode to prepare for today's podcast, I had actually also just watched a show with our youngest son about the world's biggest dogs. And of course, Great Danes make that list. Are they number one? They are not number one because the world's biggest dogs are
对。第三，它们叫声的音量可能会打扰到邻居。但就性格冷静而言，它们非常适合养在公寓里。所以当我们为了今天的播客做准备而观看这一集时，其实我刚好和我们的小儿子一起看了一个关于世界上最大的狗的节目。当然，大丹犬也上了那个榜单。它们是第一名吗？它们不是第一名，因为世界上最大的狗是根据
measured on weight and height. Oh. But they are among the tallest, standing at around 30 to 34 inches tall. And I guess Great Danes were a result of a cross breed between an English mastiff, which is the biggest dog. Oh. And the Irish wolfhound, which is the second biggest dog. Oh. So, you know, these are big, big animals. But a quote I read online about Great Danes says they are known for their kind and playful natures and make excellent family dogs. I believe it. You know, Maggie has that working shepherd in her, and she needs to be busy with a job all the time. But I think Great Danes are like, you know what, it's fine. Let's
体重和身高来衡量的。哦。但它们属于最高的犬种之一，身高大约在30到34英寸（约76-86厘米）左右。我想大丹犬是英国獒犬（体型最大的狗）杂交的结果。哦。还有爱尔兰猎狼犬（体型第二大的狗）。哦。所以，你知道的，这些都是体型非常非常大的动物。但我网上读到的一句关于大丹犬的评价说，它们以温和爱玩的性格著称，是极好的家庭伴侣犬。我信。你知道的，玛吉体内有工作牧羊犬的血统，她总是需要有工作让她忙个不停。但我觉得大丹犬的态度就是，你知道吗，没关系。我们
just hang out. Let's just watch TV. Let's just hang out. Yeah. Scooby-Doo was a Great Dan, right? Yeah. Yeah. Robby. I mean, he solved mysteries. All right. Fast fact number three is all about our director, Mark Webb. Big timey director alert, everybody. Yeah. Now, Mark started as an editor and then as a music video director. He directed videos for Good Charlotte, Snow Patrol, Maroon 5, and Green Day. I saw that and I went and watched the video. You did? Yeah. Mark's feature film debut was the movie 500 Days of Summer starring Zoe Deschanel and Joseph Gordon Levitt. If you haven't watched it, it is like just the most
就在这儿呆着吧。我们就看看电视。就这么待着。对。史酷比是一只大丹犬，对吧？对。对。罗比。我是说，他破解了谜团。好吧。第三条冷知识是关于我们的导演马克·韦布的。各位，大牌导演空降警告，大家注意啦。是的。马克最初是一名剪辑师，后来成为音乐录影带导演。他导演过美好的查洛特乐队、雪地巡警乐队、魔力红乐队和绿日乐队的MV。我看到这个就去看了那个MV。你看啦？对。马克的长片导演处女作是电影《和莎莫的500天》，由佐伊·丹斯切尔和约瑟夫·高登-莱维特主演。如果你还没看过，那简直是
charming movie ever. It's a beautiful movie. Mm-hmm. And you know what, all of his background with music videos, any wonder he was so perfect for that movie. Yeah, because there's like singing and dancing numbers in it. Mm-hmm. He also directed The Amazing Spider-Man starring Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone and the sequel The Amazing Spider-Man 2, but I believe the office was his first time directing for television. Since then, he's directed a lot of television. He's done episodes of Crazy Ex-Girlfriend and Limitless, but we started his TV career in directing. Where would he have gone without us? He is such a nice person, too.
最迷人的电影了。这是一部美丽的电影。嗯哼。你知道吗，他所有的MV背景，难怪他拍这部电影会这么完美。嗯哼。因为里面有唱歌跳舞的桥段。嗯哼。他还执导了由安德森·加菲尔德和艾玛·斯通主演的《超凡蜘蛛侠》以及续集《超凡蜘蛛侠2》，但我相信《办公室》是他第一次执导电视剧。从那以后，他执导了大量的电视剧。他拍过《疯狂前女友》和《永无止境》的剧集，但我们是开启他电视导演生涯的地方。如果没有我们，他会去哪儿呢？他也是个非常好的人。
I had just one of those moments where I put my foot in my mouth. Oh, no. I'm in front of him. So we're at one of those fancy parties, Jenna, during the award shows, you know? Yeah. I was standing there talking to Mindy and BJ and Mark walked up and we're all like, hey, I was like, how's it going? What have you been up to? And everybody just looked at me like a record scratch. And he was like, oh, I was directing a movie. And I was like, oh, good for you. That's so great. What movie? And he goes, Spider-Man. I go, no way. Way to go. And everyone in the circle clearly knew he had been directing that movie. Yes, right. It was like the
我刚好经历了那种说错话的尴尬时刻。哦，不。就在他面前。所以我们在参加某个高级派对，詹娜，在颁奖典礼期间，你知道的？是的。我站在那里和明迪还有BJ聊天，然后马克走了过来，我们都说，嘿，我就说，最近怎么样？你一直在忙什么？然后每个人都看着我，就像唱片卡壳了一样。接着他说，哦，我在导演一部电影。我就说，哦，那真为你高兴。太棒了。什么电影？他说是《蜘蛛侠》。我说，真的吗？太厉害了。圈子里的每个人显然都知道他一直在导演那部电影。是的，对。那简直是
biggest get of the year. And I was like, hey, look at you. That's so great. That's me with musicians, truly. I am not very savvy with music stuff. I remember I had a whole conversation at a party with Jack White from the White Stripes. Yeah. Just chitty-chatting, just like, oh, yeah. What do you do? Oh, my God. Oh, I'm a musician. I'm like, no way. That's so cool. And then I like walked away and I was like, that guy was so nice. And Lee was like, Jack White was so nice. I'm like, he really was. I will say this. I had a newborn at that time. And I just, I think I missed out like on two years of television or something. Like, if it
年度最大牌的项目。而我还说，嘿，你看你。太棒了。我跟音乐人在一起时也是这样，真的。我对音乐方面的东西不太懂。我记得我在一个派对上和怀特乐队的杰克·怀特聊了很久。是的。就闲聊，就像是，哦，是的。你是做什么的？天哪。哦，我是个音乐人。我说，不会吧。太酷了。然后我走开了，还说，那个人真好。李就说，杰克·怀特人真好。我说，他确实很好。我得这么说。我当时刚生完孩子。而且我感觉，我大概错过了两年的电视节目之类的。如果那不是
wasn't Sesame Street, you know, it was like, I didn't see it. Well, in my defense, I listened to music, but maybe I don't watch a lot of music videos or concerts or things. So I can't always put a face to the song. I think that's fair. Yeah. All right. That's all I got. This is a great episode. I think we're gonna have fun breaking this one down. Yeah, we have a lot of fun stuff to share from this one. Let's take a break, you guys, because when we come back, Michael might be going to the Winter Olympics. He might be. He might. He needs to confirm that room for different reasons. We are back. You guys, Michael is on the phone.
《芝麻街》，你知道的，那就相当于我完全没看过。好吧，为自己辩护一下，我听音乐，但可能我不怎么看MV、演唱会或者类似的东西。所以我没法总是把一张脸和一首歌对应起来。我觉得这很公平。嗯。好吧。我说的就这些。这是一集很棒的剧集。我想我们拆解这一集会觉得很有趣。是的，我们有很多有趣的内容要和大家分享。大家休息一下吧，因为当我们回来时，迈克尔可能会去参加冬季奥运会。他可能会去。他也许会。他需要以不同的理由确认那个房间。我们回来了。各位，迈克尔正在打电话。
He is trying to confirm his hotel reservation in Vancouver for the Winter Olympics. He's had it for years. Yeah, but the concierge can't find it. Dwight's trying to help him. He found a lot of affirmations, but no confirmation code. But then he finds it. Yes. There it is. She finds the room. She apologizes. She's like, I'm so sorry. Yeah. And she says, how can I help you, sir? And he's like, I need to cancel that. After all of that. And then she says, well, there'll be a fee. I know. If he would have just let them not find it, he probably would have gotten off without the fee. So this cold open was because the 2010 Winter
他正试图确认他在温哥华参加冬季奥运会的酒店预订。他已经订了好几年了。对，但礼宾部找不到预订记录。德怀特正试图帮他。他找到了很多积极的肯定，但就是没有确认代码。但接着他找到了。是的。找到了。她找到了房间。她道歉了。她说，我真的很抱歉。是的。然后她说，先生，有什么我可以帮您的吗？他说，我需要取消预订。经历这一切之后。然后她说，嗯，这会产生一笔手续费。我懂的。如果他刚才任由他们找不到预订，他大概就能免于这笔手续费了。所以这个开场白是因为2010年温哥华
Olympics in Vancouver started the day after this episode aired. And NBC Universal had the broadcast rights to the Olympics. And we were asked very politely to incorporate a little plug for the Olympic Games into the show. Randy Cordray said this was a very polite ask. It was not a mandate. But I said to Randy, I remember us shooting promos for the Olympics. And he said, oh, yes, we did. He even sent me the scripts for them. I couldn't find them anywhere online, Angela. I looked everywhere. We did promos for the Winter Olympics. We used to also do announcements for American Airlines in-flight television.
冬季奥运会在这一集播出后的大阪开始。而NBC环球拥有奥运会的转播权。他们非常客气地邀请我们在剧中植入一点对奥运会的宣传。兰迪·科德雷说这是一个非常礼貌的请求。这不是强制性的。但我对兰迪说，我记得我们为奥运会拍摄过宣传片。他说，哦，是的，我们拍过。他甚至把剧本发给了我。安吉拉，我在网上到处都找不到它们。我到处找过。我们为冬季奥运会拍过宣传片。我们以前还为美国航空公司的机上电视录制过广播。
That's right. Do you remember that? Yes. We would come on the little TVs in-flight and say, sit back, relax, and enjoy an episode of The Office. I totally forgot that. I remember we would do promos for the Super Bowl. We did little things for award shows. I remember all that. There's somewhere out there. I know. I wish I could have found him. Well, Jenna, this cold open actually was going to have a Michael talking head where he talked about his favorite Olympic sport. It's really funny. I want us to hear it. I love the Winter Olympics. My favorite sport is one involving men with brooms. And they
没错。你还记得吗？记得。我们会出现在机上的小电视上说：请坐好，放松，享受一集《办公室》。我完全忘了这件事。我记得我们会为超级碗拍摄宣传片。我们为颁奖典礼拍过小短片。这些我都记得。它们肯定在世界的某个角落。我知道。我真希望我能找到它们。好吧，詹娜，这个开场白原本有一个迈克尔的单采镜头，他在里面谈到了他最喜欢的奥运项目。非常搞笑。我想让我们听听看。我爱冬季奥运会。我最喜欢的项目是那种涉及拿着扫帚的男人们的项目。他们
broom the ice in front of these cylindrical discs that float gently across the ice. And they smack into one another. And no one really explains the rules, but it's mesmerizing. And there are no winners and no losers. Only poetry. And it is called curdling. Oh my god. No one explains the rules. That is how I feel when I watch curling. Or curdling, as Michael says. I always am mesmerized by it. I am. This is the most wonderful description of this sport. It's so true. I love to watch curling. I don't know what's going on. And I don't understand
在这些平缓滑过冰面的圆柱形盘子前面扫冰。它们互相碰撞。而且没有人真正解释规则，但它太迷人了。这里没有赢家，也没有输家。只有诗意。这项运动叫作“结乳酪”。天哪。没有人解释规则。这就是我看冰壶比赛时的感受。或者像迈克尔说的那样，“结乳酪”。我总是被它深深迷住。我也是。这是对这项运动最美妙的描述。太真实了。我喜欢看冰壶比赛。我不知道发生了什么。而且我不懂
who's winning and losing, but I love it. I just thought that was a great talking head. It's in the DVDs if you have them. And there was also an alt, okay? Here was the alt talking head that we shot. I got it from the shooting draft. Michael says, the winter Olympics kicks the butts out of all the other seasons of the Olympics. Pole vaulting? Try doing it on ice. Gymnastics? Yeah. Try doing that in snow. Swimming? Try doing that in an igloo with a seal. Weightlifting? You get it. Try doing that with penguins behind you the whole time. Hey, I'm lifting here.
谁赢谁输，但我就是爱看。我只是觉得那是个很棒的单采镜头。如果你有DVD的话，里面收录了这个。而且还有一个备选片段，好吗？这是我们拍摄的备选单采镜头。我是从拍摄剧本里找到的。迈克尔说：冬季奥运会把奥运会其他所有季节都比下去了。撑竿跳高？有本事在冰上试一试。体操？是的。有本事在雪地里试一试。游泳？有本事带着海豹在冰屋里试一试。举重？你懂的。有本事全程身后跟着企鹅试一试。嘿，我这正举着呢！
Oh my gosh. Anyway, I just was delighted by those and wanted to share. Those are great. I love that. Totally makes up for the fact that I couldn't find those promos. Thank you. Before we get into the episode, we want to take a minute and wish Sam and Cassie a happy birthday. Our two April birthdays. Within a week of each other. Thank you very, very much. It's very sweet. And thank you for the plant. Yes. I'll be 38 next week. This is my first plant. Everybody got a succulent this year, guys. It's the year of the succulent.
哦天哪。不管怎样，我只是被这些片段逗乐了，所以想分享给大家。太棒了。我太喜欢了。这完全弥补了我找不到那些宣传片的遗憾。谢谢。在进入正片之前，我们要花一点时间祝萨姆和卡西生日快乐。我们四月份的两个寿星。生日只差一周。非常非常感谢你们。太贴心了。谢谢你们送的植物。不客气。我下周就满38岁了。这是我的第一株植物。今年每个人都分到了一株多肉植物，各位。这是多肉植物之年。
I like it. You got a succulent pillow. I did. You started the succulent trend. Next year, you guys get a succulent pillow. Hey. Well, we just appreciate you guys so much. Oh, thank you. Thanks, guys. My pleasure. Well, as this episode begins, Joe Bennett, CEO of Sabre, who bought Dunder Mifflin's site on scene, is coming in. And it's Kathy Bates, folks. And everyone is prepping. They're cleaning. They're tidying up. Yeah. Aaron puts out some lifesaver candies. Jim puts his Sabre water bottle front and center on his desk.
我喜欢。你还拿到了一个多肉植物抱枕。没错。你引领了多肉植物的潮流。明年，你们每人都能得到一个多肉植物抱枕。嘿。好吧，我们真的非常感激你们大家。哦，谢谢。谢谢大家。不用谢。那么，随着这集开始，收购了邓德米夫林但之前没看过实地情况的萨博公司首席执行官乔·贝内特要来分公司了。各位，这就是凯西·贝茨。每个人都在做准备。他们在打扫。他们在收拾。是的。艾琳摆出了一些救生圈糖果。吉姆把他的萨博水杯放在办公桌最显眼的正中央。
Angela, you're cleaning that glass partition. I want to say I love the detail when Kathy Bates walks in. She has her purse slung over her shoulder. Yeah. It's not on her arm. She's not carrying it like a handbag. It is the greatest detail. I noticed it right away and I was like, oh, she's amazing. She has a mouth sunk. We had a fan catch from Alyssa S. in Portland, Maine. In Boo's Cruise, Michael stood on the bow and said, I am the king of the world, indicating that he has seen the movie Titanic, which Kathy Bates was in.
安吉拉，你正在擦那个玻璃隔断。我想说，当凯西·贝茨走进来时，我太喜欢那个细节了。她的钱包斜挎在肩膀上。是的。不是挎在手臂上。她不是像拿手提包那样拎着它。这是最棒的细节。我立刻注意到了，心想，哦，她太棒了。她有一个……我们收到了来自缅因州波特兰市的莉萨·S的粉丝留言。在《游轮派对》中，迈克尔站在船头说：“我是世界之王”，这暗示他看过电影《泰坦尼克号》，而凯西·贝茨正是该片的演员。
Is this a continuity error since, I mean, wouldn't Michael recognize that Joe Bennett is Kathy Bates? Well, I thought about this. That question just made my mind hurt. It's just bent the reality of the show. What about this one, though? Dave Keckner was Todd Packer, who literally starred in Anchorman with Steve Carell, so Michael Scott would have watched himself and Todd Packer in a movie. We can't apply this logic to the show. It doesn't work. What about when Timothy Oliphant comes on or Idris Elba? There goes the world. Here's the thing. It was so important to Greg Daniels in the beginning that we not cast these
这算是一个穿帮失误吗，因为——我是说，迈克尔难道认不出乔·贝内特就是凯西·贝茨吗？嗯，我思考过这个问题。这个问题让我的脑子都快想疼了。这简直扭曲了节目的现实逻辑。不过这个呢？戴夫·科克纳饰演的托德·帕克，曾与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔联袂主演过《王牌播音员》，所以迈克尔·斯科特肯定在电影里看过自己和托德·帕克。我们不能把这种逻辑套用到这部剧上。这行不通。那蒂莫西·奥利芬或伊德瑞斯·尔巴出场的时候呢？那世界观就彻底崩塌了。事情是这样的。格雷格·丹尼尔斯在一开始非常重视的一点是，我们绝不在剧中让这些
recognizable big-name actors and roles on the show for this exact reason, that it creates a logic problem. But then Steve Carell himself became a giant movie star, starring in movies that Michael Scott would surely watch. 100%. So we had to give that up at a certain point. And I'm glad we did, because then we got to work with Kathy Bates. And then, of course, we're going to have all these other people coming in as well. I mean, Amy, Ryan, Idris Elba, they kind of, you know, we slowly made our way to superstar Kathy Bates. Yeah. One of my favorite shots, I don't know why this made me laugh so hard,
高知名度的大牌演员出演角色，正是出于这个确切的原因——这会造成逻辑问题。但后来史蒂夫·卡瑞尔本人成了一名超级大电影明星，主演了许多迈克尔·斯科特肯定会看的电影。百分之百。所以我们在某个时间点不得不放弃这个原则。我很高兴我们这样做了，因为这样我们就能和凯西·贝茨合作了。当然，接下来我们还会有其他各种各样的人加入进来。我是说，艾米·瑞安、伊德瑞斯·尔巴，他们某种程度上，你知道的，我们慢慢迎来了超级巨星凯西·贝茨。是的。我最喜欢的镜头之一——不知道为什么这个把我笑得不行——
was the Great Danes jumping on Gabe. Because you and I know in real life, Zach is so tall. Yeah. And when that dog jumped on him, you really get an understanding of how big these dogs were. So the character Gabe brings them in. They immediately go right to Andy's crotch, like immediately. Well, Joe says they love a good crotch. You should take that as a compliment. Poor Ed. Ed had those Great Danes in his crotch for days. He really did. We had a fan question from Josephine E. in New York, New York. How did they get Joe's dogs to sniff Andy's crotch so incessantly? Did they put peanut butter in his pants? What did they do? Did you ask Randy? I did ask Randy. Oh, Lord, what's the answer?
就是大丹犬扑在加布身上。因为你我都知现实生活中扎克个子非常高。是的。当那只狗扑到他身上时，你真正体会到了这些狗到底有多大。所以角色加布把它们带了进来。它们径直朝安迪的裆部冲过去，就像直奔目标一样。嗯，乔说它们最喜欢好裆部。你应该把这当成一种夸赞。可怜的埃德。埃德的裆部被那些大丹犬袭击了好几天。确实如此。我们收到了来自纽约州纽约市的约瑟芬·E的粉丝提问。他们是怎么让乔的狗如此死缠烂打地去嗅安迪的裆部的？他们是在他裤子里放了花生酱吗？他们做了什么？你问过兰迪了吗？我问过兰迪。哦，天哪，答案是什么？
Well, it was a very long process. Oh, my gosh. So first, they had to budget two full days of meet and greet for both Kathy Bates and Ed Helms to bond with the dogs, because these were the two people that the dogs would be having their, like, primary interactions with. And it's funny, because remember when Ed had to skip out of lunch to go spend time with the swans? I do. Now he had to go spend time with these dogs. Well, Randy said we needed four more days of prep, where the trainers brought the dogs onto set with Kathy, Ed, and also Zach Woods. So by the time we were ready to shoot with them, these dogs were comfortable with the set. They were comfortable with the people. Here's how they got them into Ed's crotch. Okay. They applied a colorless dog
嗯，这是一个非常漫长的过程。哦，天哪。首先，他们必须预算整整两天的时间，让凯西·贝茨和埃德·赫尔姆斯与狗狗进行见面互动以建立感情，因为这两位演员将是与狗狗有“主要互动”的人。这很有趣，因为还记得埃德不得不翘掉午餐去陪天鹅的时候吗？我记得。现在他得去陪这些狗狗了。好吧，兰迪说我们还需要四天的准备时间，训练师把狗带到片场，和凯西、埃德以及扎克·伍兹一起磨合。所以当我们准备好和它们一起拍摄时，这些狗狗已经对片场感到舒适了。它们对这些演员也很习惯。以下是他们让狗钻进埃德裆部的方法。好吧。他们在埃德的戏服上涂抹了一种无色的狗
pheromone to Ed's wardrobe to get them to sniff. Randy said, quote, it did what it was supposed to. The Great Danes were in love with Ed's crotch. The total cost for this week of the dogs, including the training, the prep, the shoot days, the trainer labor, and transportation of the dogs was $14,370. Kathy Bates and Ed Helms were on The Late Late Show with James Corden, and they talked about this very thing. Here's what they had to say. I really appreciate it. Thank you. Now, you two, you know each other. You're parts of Cross because you're old friends. Yeah, you did a few episodes on The Office when Ed was on the show. What do you, what do you remember from that time? I was brilliant. Yeah, I have a hard time actually remembering you. I remember
信息素来吸引它们嗅闻。兰迪说：“原话是，它发挥了应有的作用。大丹犬爱上了埃德的裆部。”这一周涉及狗狗的总费用，包括训练、前期准备、拍摄日、训练师工时以及狗狗的交通费，总计14,370美元。凯西·贝茨和埃德·赫尔姆斯曾做客詹姆斯·柯登的《深夜秀》，他们在节目中谈到了这件事。以下是他们的谈话内容。非常感谢。谢谢你们。现在，你们两个，你们互相认识。你们曾经交过手，因为你们是老朋友。是的，当埃德在节目中时，你客串过几集《办公室》。你对那段时光有什么记忆？我表现得很惊艳。是的，我其实很难记起你。我只记得
The Great Danes. That's right, because in the show you had two, and they were huge. Huge, they're huge. They're great. They were great. Yeah, they were. But didn't they have to try and inspect your crotch or something? Is this true? Yeah, that's why I forgot. Well, yeah, there was some bit where the Great Danes were obsessed with my crotch, which was in the script, and then I really had to do it when it happened. And the only way to do that is to actually put dog treats in your zipper, right? I didn't know that. I thought it was just you. I thought it was your unique charisma. Well, yeah, I am something of a dog whisperer, a Great Danes whisperer. But I mean, that's a big animal to have in your right there without
大丹犬。没错，因为在节目里你有两只，而且它们体型巨大。巨大，它们真的巨大。它们很棒。它们确实很棒。是的，它们是的。但它们是不是不得不试图检查你的裆部还是怎么回事？这是真的吗？对，这就是我为什么忘不了。嗯，对，剧本里有一段情节是大丹犬对我的裆部着迷，然后当事情发生时我真的得配合演。而做到这一点的唯一方法就是在你的拉链里放狗零食，对吧？我不知道。我以为那只是你。我以为那是你独特的个人魅力。好吧，是的，我某种程度上算是个训狗师，大丹犬训狗师。但我的意思是，在那种情况下，身边有那么大一只动物……毫无疑问。而且，我的意思是，这真的很有趣，直到有人“丢了球”。所以不得不说，我确实记得在拍某些场景时，我记得埃德不得不把那些零食塞进他的裤子里。我也记得。看起来就像一个小小的，你知道的，那种像意大利辣香肠一样的狗零食，你知道的，那些小零食，所以他们会拿那些东西，然后他必须把它们塞进拉链里，好让它们真的去猛扑。是的，就像，呃，它们是。哦天哪。哦天哪。好吧，我数了数埃德有狗袭击裆部的场景有多少次。这大概就是“裆部嗅探器追踪器”了吧。我太喜欢我们追踪的这些东西了。所以大家和我们一起看，就会看看你们最后数出来的数字是不是一样。安迪要告诉我们大家，情人节
question. And it's, I mean, it is, it's all fun and games until someone loses a ball. So I have to say, I do remember that for some of the scenes, I remember Ed having to put those like treats in his pants. I do too. It almost looked like a little, you know, that dog treat like pepperoni, you know, those little, so they would take those and he would have to kind of mush them into the zipper to really get them to go at it. Yeah, like, nah, they are. Oh Lord. Oh my gosh. Well, I counted how many scenes that Ed had a dog in his crotch. It's the crotch sniffer tracker, I guess. I love the things we track. So watch along with us and you'll see if you get the same number at the end. Andy is going to share with us, you guys, that Valentine's is
马上就要到了。他和艾琳还没约过会，他想送她一个情人节礼物，但他又不想让她知道他喜欢她。这就是我的问题。我只想让他直接告诉她他喜欢她。我知道。因此，他给每个人都准备了情人节礼物，并分发给所有人，除了梅雷迪思，他是把礼物直接“砸”向她的。擦伤了她的脖子。她有一个单采镜头。你注意到她又穿着那件背心了吗？我注意到了。这难道是史上穿得最多的背心吗？这简直是梅雷迪思最喜欢的背心。这是她的标志性背心。确实是。疯狂的是，当我们拍摄这部剧时，我不记得这件背心总是出现。对吧？但现在看的时候，感觉每隔一集就会出现这件背心。我知道。下一场戏是迈克尔
right around the corner. He and Aaron haven't gone on any dates and he wants to give her a Valentine but he doesn't want her to know that he likes her. This is my problem. I just want him to tell her he likes her. I know. So as a result, he gets everyone a Valentine's and he's handing them out to everybody except he flings Meredith at her. It cuts her throat. She has a talking head. Did you notice she's wearing the vest again? I did. Is this the most worn vest ever? This is like Meredith's favorite vest. It's her go-to vest. It really is. The crazy thing is when we were filming the show, I don't remember this vest like always being around. Right? But now watching it, it's like every other episode there is the best. I know. Our next scene is Michael
和吉姆在会议室里，他们试图向乔·贝内特解释为什么这个岗位需要设置两个职位，对吧？是的。进展并不顺利。迈克尔一开口就把佛罗里达比作一个无法无天的沼泽。没错。詹娜，这让我想起了互联网上曾一度病毒式传播的那个梗：你输入你的生日，然后在谷歌搜索你的生日，再加上“佛罗里达男”（Florida Man）这几个字。你试过吗？没有。哦，我试过。准备好了吗？这是我的生日搜出来的结果，然后我们该查查你的了。好的。我输入了6月25日，“佛罗里达男”。这是我搜到的结果。好吧。佛罗里达男因在沃尔玛停车场赤身裸体奔跑被捕，2019年6月25日下午1点05分。哦，我们也许该为了庆祝萨姆和卡西的生日再查一个。我比你先想到了。哦。佛罗里达男被指控向一名女子发射装满尿液的
and Jim in the conference room and they're trying to explain to Joe Bennett why there needs to be two positions for this job, right? Yeah. It's not going great. Michael starts off comparing Florida to a lawless swamp. Yep. Jenna, it made me think of that thing that went viral on the internet where you would take your birthday and you would Google your birthday and then the words Florida Man. Did you do it? No. Oh, I did it. Ready? Here's what mine had and then we should do yours. Okay. I typed in June 25th, Florida Man. This is what I got. Okay. Florida Man arrested for running naked through Walmart parking lot June 25th, 2019, 1.05 p.m. Oh, we should maybe in honor of Sam and Cassie's birthday. One step ahead of you. Oh. Florida Man accused of firing a urine-filled
水枪。哦天哪。2019年4月16日。卡西？我搜到的是：佛罗里达男在争吵后用“大嘴比利·巴斯”唱歌鱼拍打别人的嘴。太神奇了。哦天哪。拍打的时候鱼还在唱歌吗？好吧。我搜到的是：佛罗里达男试图携火箭推进式榴弹发射器登机。哦天哪。不管怎样，这算是一种有趣的鸡尾酒会游戏。在“佛罗里达男”后面输入你的生日，看看你会搜到什么。萨姆，我觉得你赢了。这其实是两个结果中的一个。还有一个是，佛罗里达男因假扮警察拦截便衣警察而被捕。哦，不。哦天哪。我们爱你，佛罗里达。好吧，乔在这场会议室戏里可不容任何人愚弄。她有一句精彩绝伦的名言。她说：“你不能给我肉汁却告诉我那是果冻，因为
squirt gun at woman. Oh my gosh. April 16th, 2019. Cassie? I got Florida Man slapped with big mouth Billy Bass singing fish after argument. Amazing. Oh my gosh. Was it singing when the slap occurred? Okay. Mine is Florida Man attempts to board plane with rocket-propelled grenade launcher. Oh my gosh. Anyway, it's sort of a fun cocktail party game. Type in your birthday in Florida Man and see what you get. Sam, I think yours wins. This is actually one of two. Also, Florida Man arrested for pulling over undercover cop while pretending to be a cop. Oh no. Oh my goodness. We love you, Florida. Well, Joe is not suffering any fools in this conference room scene. She has an amazing quote. She says, you can't give me gravy and tell me it's jelly because
肉汁可一点都不甜。”这随后激发了迈克尔试图用同样的南方俚语说话。他是这么说的。我觉得我们必须读出来。他说：“嗯，吉姆，在我老家，有两种人：一种是不属于那类的人，另一种是‘草蜢子那么高’的人。你是哪种不属于哪类的人呢？欢迎下次光临。”是的。迈克尔说的是“草蜢子那么高”（knee-high on a grasshopper）。这个俗语其实是“齐膝高”（knee-high to a grasshopper）。这让我想到了南方俚语，因为我很喜欢她那个果冻肉汁的比喻。其实我真的 literalmente 喜欢乔·贝内特说的每一句话，因为在这段对话结束时，当他们不同意她的观点时，她说“我们让它发酵一下”。是的。这基本上意味着“我给你们到今天结束的时间来同意我的观点”。是的。就先消化消化。
gravy ain't sweet. And this then inspires Michael to try to speak in these same sort of like southern phrases. This is what he says. I felt like we had to read it. He said, well, Jim, where I'm from, two types of folk, those who ain't and those who are knee-high on a grasshopper. Which type ain't you ain't? Y'all come back now. Yes. Michael says knee-high on a grasshopper. The phrase is knee-high to a grasshopper. This got me thinking about southern phrases because I loved her little jelly gravy thing. I actually literally love everything Joe Bennett says because at the end of this conversation when they're disagreeing with her, she says we'll let it marinate. Yeah. Which basically means I'm going to give you till the end of the day to agree with me. Yeah. Just go sitting it.
真的很喜欢。所有这些引导我找到了一篇名为《十句南方俗语》的文章，刊登在《开阔的乡村》杂志上。大多数人都得查查字典。好吧。“齐膝高的草蜢子”就在上面。这只是意味着，你个子矮。我曾经被人说过我“齐膝高的草蜢子”。是的。因为我个子不高。它也可以用来形容你长高了。比如，哦，上次见到你时，你还只是个齐膝高的草蜢子呢。看看你现在。是的。我用得好吗？我用得不错吧？相当不错。相当不错。确实挺不错的。好吧，那么文章里还有更多俗语。安吉拉，作为我们的南方女士专家。我不知道自己算不算专家。不过我已经准备好了。你准备好了吗？第一条，别把你的内裤打成结（别把事情搞得一团糟）。明白了。别为小事心烦意乱。
Really like it. All of this led me to an article in wide open country called Ten Southern Sayings. Most people have to look up. Okay. So knee-high to a grasshopper was on there. It just means that, you know, you're short. I have been told that I'm knee-high to a grasshopper. Yes. Because I'm a short stack. It can also be used to say like you've grown. Like, oh, last time I saw you, you were just knee-high to a grasshopper. Look at you now. Yeah. Was that a good? Did I do a good? Pretty good. Pretty good. That is pretty good. All right. So here are some more phrases in the article. Angela, as our southern lady expert. I don't know if I'm an expert. I'm ready though. Are you ready? Number one, don't get your knickers in a knot. Got it. Don't get upset about little
当心你的裤子。诸如此类。你比冬天的糖蜜还要慢。那可真是慢极了，因为糖蜜在冬天会变硬。嗯哼。继续。哦，真可怜你的心（好心塞/可怜呐）。哦，那可是一句复杂的话。有好几种用法呢。我的意思是，我最喜欢的使用方法是，你知道的，基本上就在你说了某句不得体的话之后。你知道的，你会说：“哦，看看她的上衣。真可怜她的心。”嗯。那意思是他们不喜欢你的上衣。就是这个意思。文章说，在你以为你妈妈的朋友是在给你一个甜美的赞美之前，你最好仔细检查一下里面有没有讽刺意味，因为通常南方女性的八卦都是以“真可怜她的心”开始或结束的。叮，叮，叮。懂了。最后，亲爱的，那条狗是不会去打猎的。
things. Watch your britches. Stuff like that. You're slower than molasses in the winter. That's pretty slow because molasses gets hard in the winter. Mm-hmm. Keep going. Oh, bless your heart. Oh, well, that's a complicated one. There's several ways to use that one. I mean, my favorite way to use it is, you know, basically right after you say something tacky. You know, you're like, oh, look at her blouse. Bless her heart. Hmm. That means they didn't like your top. That's what it said. It said, before you think your mom's friend is giving you a sweet compliment, you might want to double check for sarcasm because typically southern women's gossip begins or ends with bless their heart. Ding, ding, ding. Got it. And finally, honey, that dog won't hunt.
哦，是的。我也听过这个。我的意思是，基本上“那条狗不会去打猎”的意思是：你在那件事上是不会成功的。那是不可能的。是的。是的。这就好像是个糟糕的主意。对吧。比如，想象你有一只你以为是猎犬的狗，但它不去追野鸭，然后你就会说：“哦，是的，那只狗是不会去打猎的。”我真的很喜欢这句。嗯哼。我就在想，我想让乔·贝内特用这句话。是的。在所有这些里我最喜欢的就是“亲爱的，那条狗可不会去打猎”。你知道，我爸爸以前常说的一句不在那个列表里的话吗。我不知道南方其他人是不是也这么说，但我爸爸以前常说：“哦，他全速冲进去了（wide open）。”那是什么意思？我不知道这是否只是我爸爸会说的话，
Oh, yes. I've heard this too. I mean, basically that dog won't hunt. It's like, you're not going to have any success with that. That's not going to happen. Yes. Yeah. It's like a bad idea. Right. Like, imagine you have a dog who thinks a hunting dog and it doesn't go after the duck and you're just like, oh, yeah, that dog's not going to hunt. I really like that one. Mm-hmm. I was like, I want Joe Bennett to use it. Yeah. That was my favorite of all of them was honey, that dog won't hunt. You know, one that my dad used to say that's not on that list. I don't know if other people from the south say this, but my dad used to say, oh, he went in there wide open. What does that mean? I don't know if this is just something my dad would say,
但那的意思是，如果你，呃，跃跃欲试、急不可耐的话，如果你对某事充满热情，你就会“全速”冲进一个房间。天哪，他全速冲进去了。哦，好吧。这就是比尔·金西的风格。好吧，乔·贝内特将有一个单采镜头。我觉得这很有趣，因为这是她与摄像团队一对一的高光时刻。嗯哼。所以她买下了这家公司。她同意让摄像团队继续拍摄，因为她本可以把他们赶出去的，对吧？她是新老板。是的。她坐下来，向他们讲述了她的一些个人履历数据，对吧？嗯，在这个单采镜头中，我们看到了乔·贝内特在不同地方与不同名人、不同政要合影的照片蒙太奇。兰迪·科德雷说：
but that meant like, if you're like, um, hot to trot guys, if you're fired up about something, you like go into a room wide open. Oh man, he went in there wide open. Oh, okay. All right. That was a Bill Kinsey for you. Well, Joe Bennett is going to have a talking head. I found this interesting because this is her moment one-on-one with the camera crew. Mm-hmm. So she has bought this company. She has agreed to let the camera crew keep filming because she could have just kicked them out, right? She's the new owner. Yes. And she sits down and she tells them sort of like all of her stats, right? Yeah. Well, during this talking head, we see a photo montage of Joe Bennett in various places with different celebrities, different politicians. Randy Cordray said,
我们是这样制作的，我们在仓库舞台上搭建了一个绿幕，迈克尔·加伦堡拍摄了凯西·贝茨穿着不同服装的照片。比如开飞机的那套？是的，穿着飞行员服装。然后我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩将她P图合成到合法的图库照片中。所以，是的，这就像是一个令人惊叹的P图杰作，但确实有真实的底片。在真实的照片里那架飞机上有另一个女人，但我们把凯西·贝茨P进去了。好吧，我们在这个单采镜头中得知她的名字其实叫乔琳·贝内特。我是说，乔琳是我最喜欢的桃莉·巴顿的歌。当然。我们必须听一小段。好的。为了向乔琳·贝内特致敬。是的。桃莉·巴顿是国宝。我爱她。爱她。我爱那首歌。顺便说一句，在这个
the way we did this, we set up a green screen on the warehouse stage and Michael Gallenberg shot Kathy Bates in different outfits. Like flying the plane? Yes, in a plane outfit. And our graphic designer, Henry Sain, then photoshopped her into licensed stock photo images. So yeah, it was just like an amazing photoshop job, but there are photos out there. There's like another woman in that plane in the real picture, but we put Kathy Bates in it. Well, we learned in this talking head that her name is actually Jolene Bennett. I mean, Jolene is my favorite Dolly Parton song. Of course. We have to hear a tiny bit of it. All right. In honor of Jolene Bennett. Yes. Dolly Parton is a national treasure. I love her. Love her. I love that song. Incidentally, in this
单采镜头里，大丹犬是加比。哦，原来是它。那是我们的狗演员。那是我们的狗演员。干得好，加比。好吧，安迪要送给艾琳她的情人节礼物了。那是史努比和伍德斯托克。是的，他送给他是因为，你知道的，因为所有的鸟。是的，从圣诞节开始。我最喜欢他说“这是史努比和伍德斯托克”，然后她说：“哦，你给它们起名字了。”是的。他说：“哦，不。”好吧，我稍微扯远了一点，聊到了史努比和伍德斯托克。你知道的，它们是查尔斯·舒尔茨创作的漫画《花生漫画》里的狗和小鸟。它们是好朋友。你知道史努比和伍德斯托克的起源故事吗？因为那真的超级可爱。我不知道。我想听听，因为我小时候有一个史努比玩偶。我到处带着它。所以伍德斯托克最初出现的时候是在
talking head, Gabby was the great Dane. Oh, that's who. That was our dog actor. That was our dog actor. Very good job, Gabby. Well, Andy is going to give Aaron her Valentine. It's Snoopy and Woodstock. Yes, he gives it to her because, you know, of all the birds. Yeah, from Christmas. I loved when he said it's Snoopy and Woodstock and she goes, Oh, you named them. Yes. He's like, Oh, no. Well, I went on a little tangent about Snoopy and Woodstock. You know, they're the dog and bird in the peanut comic strip by Charles Schultz. They're great friends. Do you know the origin story of Snoopy and Woodstock? Because it's freaking adorable. I don't. And I want to hear it because I had a Snoopy growing up. I carried everywhere. So Woodstock first appeared when a
会说话的头，加比是大丹犬。哦，原来是这样。那是我们的狗演员。那是我们的狗演员。干得好，加比。嗯，安迪要给亚伦送情人节礼物。那是史努比和伍德斯托ック。是的，他把它送给她，因为，你知道的，为了所有的鸟。对，从圣诞节开始。我喜欢当他说那是史努比和伍德斯托克时，她说，哦，你给它们起名字了。是的。他就像，哦，不。嗯，我稍微跑题讲了一下史努比和伍德斯托克。你知道，它们是查尔斯·舒尔茨的《花生漫画》里的狗和鸟。它们是好朋友。你知道史努比和伍德斯托克的起源故事吗？因为这太可爱了。我不知道。我想听听，因为我从小就有一个史努比。我到处带着它。所以伍德斯托克第一次出现是在一个
mama bird built her nest on Snoopy's stomach while he was taking a nap. And the mama bird never came back. So there were two baby birds and Snoopy had to kind of reluctantly raise them. But one day, Snoopy got so upset that he just threw the two birds out into the world to fend for themselves. But one of the birds came back. And Snoopy was like very annoyed. This is part of the story. But then he decided he would go ahead and raise the bird himself and he became quite attached to it. And that bird was Woodstock. Now the little bird did not even have a name until June of 1970. He was named after the Woodstock Musical Festival of 1969. Snoopy is the only non bird who understands Woodstock's language. When you read the comic strip, it's just a series of exclamation
points and question marks. But Woodstock still likes to sleep on Snoopy's stomach. And he always turns to Snoopy for help when he has a problem. That's so sweet. It's so sweet. I love Snoopy and Woodstock. So this is actually a very romantic card, especially if you know the backstory. It's just about two creatures that need to be together. But Erin didn't even know who they were, their names. So for Erin, it's a dog and a bird. And she's like, oh, they're friends. Yeah. Not the right message, even though he did spray it with Roger Federer Cologne. It has pheromones in it, the tennis player. All right, listen, now it's time for a conference room meeting.
I have a fan girl moment of five minutes, 52 seconds. What is it? Kathy Bates put her hand on my back. Chop chop, little onion. Do you see my reaction? I was supposed to act like sort of like thrown off by it, but it wasn't that hard to play because I was all like, okay, Kathy Bates talking to me. I was jealous. You got an actual like direct moment with Joe Bennett. It's so great. So everyone's taking their seats and Kevin goes, Joe, there's books in my chair. Like he's disturbed. Like why is there a book in my chair? Yeah, he can't sit in it. Yes, she says, one is the Saber handbook and the other is my autobiography. At six minutes, four seconds, we see a really good shot of her book.
Her book is called Take a Good Look. And this was another creation by Henry Sane, our graphic designer. Michael Gallenberg had taken a picture of Kathy Bates the week prior when they were on the set of the Saber exterior for the crazy Saber video. And they made this book, Take a Good Look. Well, you know, this scene was extended. A lot of it got trimmed. Pam actually asked Joe Bennett, why is it called Take a Good Look? And I thought we should hear her answer. Ooh. I was 26 years old working at Kodak. It was my first job after Vanderbilt. It was very exciting. I took it very seriously. But I wasn't afforded the same amount of respect
that the rest of the board enjoyed. One day, I'd had it up to here and I strode into the boardroom where nothing but a pair of spike heels, a lace push-up bra and matching lace panties. And I took my seat and I looked around at all of them and I said, gentlemen, if this is all you see, then take a good look. Ooh, I love Joe Bennett. Well, it says in the script, people are blown away by this well-rehearsed anecdote. Well, she's got a whole very sort of charming speech where she's like, who is Saber? Where is Tallahassee? In Texas. Right. Michael knows. This is when she's going
to reveal you all are going to be selling printers. Printers. Michael starts saying, oh, I can manage that. He says manage as many times as possible because he's trying to put subliminal messages into Joe's brain. He's the manager. Which is the same thing that Kelly did in Michael Scott paper company with Charles Minor when she kept saying, you wanted me? Yes. You want me? That's my favorite one. Joe wraps up this meeting but doesn't take any questions. People's hands go up. She's like out the door. She's like, sell my printers. I'm gone. So badass. She's a badass lady. I love this lady. I think Joe and I would be friends. Oh, for sure. In real life? I think we would. We might be the same woman.
All right. Why don't we take a break? Because we're about halfway through. And when we come back, Kelly is going to get a Valentine from Andy. With the most flowery message. Yeah. Not a dog and a bird. No. Words of love. We'll be back. We are back. Kelly is reading her Valentine from Andy. Oh my God. Oh my God. We don't know what's in it yet, but it is clearly touched her heart. You guys, Kelly has never thought of Andy that way. But that's what romantic comedies are based on. It's always the person that you didn't even notice or that maybe you even hated. Right. He's been there all along, you guys. Kelly is living in a pretend rom-com and she has found her leading man. She has. Can we talk
about how adorable, by the way, Mindy looks in this episode? She is so cute, head to toe, her outfit, her hair, her makeup. She looks so cute. I know. Well, Pam is going to stumble on something for Jim. She ran the numbers, looked at the manual. He could make way more money as a salesman than a manager. Yeah. Because Saber has all these incentive programs, which are outlined in the manual that Pam read. I just want to point out who read the manual. I know. I know. It was Pam, not Jim. And this is going to touch on something that I speak to a lot of women about, which is the invisible labor that women do in our lives, in our partnerships, in our jobs. Guys, if you believe women should have larger pockets, I encourage you to google the phrase
invisible labor and read up on it because it's very, very satisfying. It's basically just about how women read and track details. Like emails. An example of invisible labor would be reading the email from the school, making note of when picture day is, making sure that your kids have their favorite outfits and that their hair is brushed before they walk out the door for picture day. That's just an example of invisible labor. But another example of invisible labor are the number of ways that women are asked to work for free, to volunteer for things at their job, for committees, for making sure that someone gets their birthday cake or whatever at the office. All of these things are like additional invisible labor type jobs that tend to fall
on women's shoulders. And there are a number of like sociological articles about it. I mean, room parrot. Yeah. You know, at school, who's bringing in all the like little crafts for the craft thing that the school needs, things like that. Invisible labor. Everybody, check it out. Also pockets. Well, with this information that Pam gives Jim, he tells Michael, you know what? Go for it. You'll be the manager. Michael is so happy that Jim came to his senses. He goes in the break room because he has to brag to someone. He's wandering around finding someone he can brag to basically. Exactly. Someone's got to know this information. Oscar is quietly reading a magazine. It's The Atlantic. Michael's favorite ocean. Yes. And there was a deleted talking head
where Michael discusses why the Atlantic is his favorite ocean. Oh, I just love the idea that Michael thinks there is this ongoing periodical about the Atlantic Ocean that Oscar reads. Just about the Atlantic Ocean. Yes. What's happening in the Atlantic? Well, you know, we've already learned his favorite winter Olympic sport. So now let's find out all about his favorite ocean. Why is the Atlantic Ocean the best ocean? That is simple. According to Oprah, the Pacific Ocean is pretty much just garbage. The Indian Ocean is full of pirates. The Arctic Ocean is too cold. Thank you very much. And the Southern Ocean is just the bottom of all the other oceans. Atlantic Ocean has all the history. That is where the amoebas crawl from the murky
depths and became man. So it's pretty cool. Wow. That's what he thinks. Makes me laugh so hard about the Atlantic Ocean. He also does this thing in this talking head that I mean, we all know people that do this, but it never quite makes sense. He's like, the Arctic Ocean's too cold. Thank you very much. Yeah. Well, thank you very much. Like, what? Anyway, that's in the DVDs. I just thought it was hilarious. I love it that this scene cut away to a talking head of Michael explaining this. Right. And then cuts back to this scene where Oscar finds out why Michael is so happy. He's like, well, maybe I should be a salesperson too. Yeah. And Michael's like, what are you talking about? Yeah. And he's like, they make way more money. It's in the manual.
Saber has no cap on commissions. He read it all in the manual. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Michael has his talking head. He's like, well, according to the manual, there is no cap on commissions. I have been hustled. Yeah. So Michael is going to walk in on Joe in the conference room having a meeting with Jim where Jim is saying he'll be a salesperson. He does my favorite thing too. He whispers, son of a bitch. I want to point out that this conference room went from being a place where we were having a presentation with rows of chairs and now having a table in the middle of it, it's gone back and forth between like sort of office style for Joe with the conference table to presentation style. And we never see this transformation happen on the show. Never. No
one's ever moving a table in and out. Where does the table go when we're not using it? Who's moving at all? Who is it? All I want is B-roll of like Kevin and whoever create just moving chairs and tables all day. I feel like there's a missed opportunity here. I would love it if like Michael designated this to the warehouse guys. And can you imagine just like how annoyed they have to come up and move everything? Yes. What if there's just an episode where they're moving it back and forth all day? And Darryl is like, Michael, we have deliveries to make. Or Michael pays like petty cash to Leo and Gino. Yes. And they come and move everything from Vance refrigeration. Oh my god. I know. This is how does it happen? Who is the muscle here? How does it happen? Yes. We also had
a continuity catch in this scene. I did too. The hair? Yes. Yes. You and Jess B from Batesville, Indiana. When Michael and Jim are talking with Joe, Michael messes up Jim's hair and it stays disheveled until the very end when Michael gets up to leave and then it is perfectly combed again. Yes. At nine minutes, 13 seconds, messy hair. That's when it starts. It stays messy until 955. And then at 958, it's perfectly back to normal. Right. Nice catch. So in addition to messing up Jim's hair, Michael also messes up Jim's plans. Do you like that segue? I just thought of it in the moment. I'm really kind of proud of it. You're like a professional. I feel like I am. I mean, after like a hundred and something episodes. You're like a wordsmith. Thank you. Basically,
Michael says, you know, I think I want to be the salesperson. And Joe says, you know what, Michael? You have more experience across the board. You've been in sales. You've been a manager. I'm going to defer to your judgment on this. And he takes the sales position and now he's got to move in all his stuff to Jim's little desk. And Jim is now moving into Michael's office. Yes. You see Jim and Pam. Jim is the manager now. At 10 minutes, six seconds, you're going to get a real good shot of belly bump E. This was a very large belly bump that I had to wear. Pam has gone up a bump. Well, she's getting into her last trimester. Yeah. Next week, she's giving birth everybody. Yeah. Well, Dwight is not pleased at all. He makes a phone call
to Bobcat. Yeah. Bobcat, this is dragon. Meet me by the dumpster in 90 seconds. And he hangs up and goes 89, 88. 20 minutes later, Ryan meets him outside by the dumpsters. Do you mean Scarfy Ryan? Because I'm calling him Scarfy Ryan. Such a scarf. A turquoise scarf. You know, in the shooting draft, because I reread it, Joe Bennett says, nice scarf. Oh, she comments on a scarf earlier in the episode. But yeah, if you want to see Scarfy, go to 10 minutes, 32 seconds. They have this hilarious dialogue too. When Ryan says, did you see saw? And Dwight goes, of course I see saw. Mose and I see saw all the time. Yeah. He's like, no, the movie saw. Because they still have their diabolical plan to take down Jim. And Ryan's idea is that what? They're going to kidnap Jim and like
do psychological torture on him. Dwight rejects the idea. He does. Like this is not a good idea. I do want to say in this scene, a nice touch at 10 minutes, 30 seconds. That's some nice, fakie snow on the dumpster kind of around was provided by Ron Neri's team from ANA special effects. Again, they had to bring in a small truckload of ice. It was delivered from Union Ice of North Hollywood, California. They put it through the industrial woodchipper device, and it sprayed out as snow. I appreciate this. I mean, we filmed this in Southern California, but we knew that this would be airing in a Pennsylvania winter time frame. And so we put these little details in. Well done. I love it too. Paints the picture guys. Well, ultimately Dwight
and Ryan decide they're going to reach out to Nick, the IT guy, make him their pawn and help him bring down Jim. Yeah. Back in the office, Aaron is helping Michael try and get all his toys onto the desk, but she's having trouble. There's not as many surfaces. I want to point out two things in the scene. At 11 minutes 57 seconds, there's a really good shot of the giraffe pen in my cup holder on my desk. The wonky one. The wonky giraffe. That never worked. That never worked. That you still have. That I still have. Aw. So if you want a good shot of it, it was a lot harder to see when it was at reception, but it's really good to see in the scene. Wonky giraffe. I also want to say how much I loved having Steve Carell at this desk clump. It took us about a half a day
to shoot all the scenes with Steve out in the bullpen. It was a delight. I absolutely loved it. He loved it. We got to be together. It was so fun. I would be so tickled if he ever had to sit over in accounting. Yes, right. Exactly. Aaron's going to enter Jim's office with ants on a log. You really get some insight into the things that Michael has convinced Aaron to do for him, none of which Pam would have ever done. No, they have a whole different relationship. And she's so earnestly like believes in Michael's just, I don't know what in his, she looks up to him. Right. I think she believes that he really does have this handbook on how to be a boss. And this is what you do. You bring ants on a log every day at two o'clock. You also
have to get spun in your chair because a spinning brain is a working brain. Yeah, ants on a log, guys, celery, stalk, some peanut butter and a few raisins. That's it. It's a great snack. It's a great snack. Have you ever done it where instead of raisins, you put chocolate chips? Oh, I'd probably like that better because I love chocolate with peanut butter. Right? Oh, it's real good. Does the celery throw you off though? No, it still has the crisp, refreshing crunch. Okay. Well, Michael's going to blow his train horn and say that he got a new client and he instantly gets shade for this. People are like, we don't really announce when we get sales anymore. We haven't done that since 1992.
I mean, come on. So this scene continued, Jenna. It's in the shooting draft. It didn't make it in the final episode. I thought it was really cute. Michael is annoyed. So he goes, well, I guess I'll just celebrate with a snack then. And he walks into the kitchen and then you see sort of like this argument between Oscar and Michael like through the kitchen door and then Michael storms out and they're having this heated conversation and Michael's like, you know how long it took for those to freeze? And we see that Oscar has a little orange cube on like a toothpick, like a homemade popsicle. Oh, like in the ice tray where you put orange juice in your ice tray. Yes. Yeah. So Michael's furious and Oscar's like,
that's because you kept opening the freezer door to check on them. And Michael goes, yeah, but then I didn't check on them and now they're all gone and the camera widens and we see Creed and Meredith each eating one. Everyone was eating Michael's homemade orange juice popsicles and he's furious about it. It was just this little runner that got cut and then he goes and sits down and he smells the smell. Oh, the smell. Yes. So he's not having a very good day in the bullpen. Yeah, we find out that there is a kind of sulfur like smell. It is a side effect of Phyllis's new allergy medication. She sent an email about it. She did and everyone seems fine with it. Even though Andy has tissues up his nose, he's just anticipating a nose bleed.
This is it for Michael. He cannot believe he's out in the bullpen where you don't celebrate a sale. People are taking your homemade orange juice ice cube popsicles and there's a sulfur smell. And it's stinky. And he can't fit his things on his desk. I also want to point out something else in this scene actually. It's at 16 minutes and seven seconds. There is a really good shot of the three hamster dolls on Michael's desk. And the reason I point this out, I think we shared this a long time ago. But back when we shot the pilot, John Krasinski toured a paper company in Scranton. The manager there was a woman and she had a little stuffed hamster on her desk. And so Michael's little hamster toys are a nod to that little bit of research that John Krasinski
did. And I just love that we have kept this detail going. All these years. Yes. I remember it was so important to Greg. He was like, no, we need the hamster's dressed up. Yeah, we need little dressed up ham. Everyone was like, what is this detail? He's like, I need it. It was like part of that authenticity. He loved spotting that in that video that John showed him. Oh my gosh, Angela, I just saw one more thing I didn't mention. There's a lot to unpack in these scenes where Michael is sitting out in the bullpen. There was a fan catch from Page M in Utica, New York. When Michael announces his sale, Jim's door is closed in the background, but then it's open at the end of the scene. It's another thing like the hair mess up. I love all the background
catches, you guys. Good catch, Paige. Kelly is now going to read Andy's card. It's one of those cards you guys that you buy and it has a whole message written in it. Here's what it says. You brighten my day with the sound of your voice. You bring so much laughter and love. You're everything to me. And I was so blessed when God sent you here to me. To which Erin says, jeez Louise. Yeah, then she has the talking head where she says she just can't compete with Kelly. Kelly can sing, she can dance, she gets all of her clothes at the mall. I mean, it makes total sense to her that Andy would pick Kelly. I mean, if you're looking at the two cards and you don't know anything about Snoopy or Woodstock, Kelly's card is beautiful.
It is. Andy said he had no idea what was on the card. No, he clearly picked out Erin's card and then just like quickly grabbed a bunch of others and handed them out randomly. Yeah, for all we know, Kevin got a similar card. True, with no candy. I don't know if you noticed the location, the location of Erin's talking head. She couldn't be in the conference room because that's where Joe and her Great Danes are. So we would set up an alternate talking head spot outside of the break room. Yes, there's the little hallway and many talking heads would happen there. But that's why there's a plant. If you see a plant in a talking head, we're probably in that break room hallway. Speaking of the break room, Dwight and Ryan are going to find Nick in there. Nick, the IT guy,
and they're kind of going to like do a shakedown. Is that what it's called? Yeah, I think it is a shakedown. I don't know if that's the right term, but basically they're like... It is the right term because I just watched an episode of Abbott Elementary and they have a whole plot line about shakedowns. Okay, so there's a shakedown. I learned something. There you have it. They're basically like, Nick, you're going to help us get Jim's password to his computer. And if you don't, we're going to do these kind of things. And then Ryan has to struggle to crush a can, yes. But then Dwight completely crushes an apple. Yeah, we got a fan question from Laura S in Australia. How did Rain crush the apple? Was it a fakey apple or is he just super strong?
Her Randy Cordray, Dwight's crushing of the apple, was just real. They used a real apple. He said they did a bunch of practice runs. They didn't drill any holes in it or like help him a little. Okay, so they did kind of score the back side of the apple so that it could break away more easily, but they didn't do anything to the front. It's a real apple. He said Rain's fingertips were just strong enough to dig into the front of the apple and then it broke away because of some of the scoring on the back. But I mean, just that part, the part where they go into the front is really impressive. Good job, Rain. Who know? You know, that's the thing. Like as an actor, especially being a television actor, because they generate scripts on an ongoing basis,
and they'll just write something. And suddenly you're like, oh, I guess this week I'm skateboarding. I've never been on a skateboard before. And then you have like one week to figure out how to be a good enough skateboarder to pull off whatever they've written. And in this case, like how lucky are they that Rain could crush an apple with his fingertips? No one asked. And then if he couldn't have done it, what would they have done? Would they have rewritten it? Would they have found a fakey apple? I don't know. Our romantic comedy is about to begin. Kelly's at the copier. Yeah. Andy walks up behind her and she turns around and goes, oh, you scared me. I didn't see you there. I mean, she is laying it on so thick. She touches his arm, gives him a kiss on the cheek.
He's so confused. He's so confused. And that's when Meredith comes up and goes, we saw the card you gave her. He gave that to me. We'd be doing it. I know something like that. And he's like, what? Now Andy's freaked out. He realizes what has happened and Aaron has seen the whole thing. Mm hmm. Meanwhile, Michael is going to walk into what is now Jim's office and say he wants his old job back because he cannot handle the farty dirt patch that is the sales floor. Well, Jim is says the grass is always greener and he's like, there's no grass out there. Just a farty dirt patch. It's amazing. Jim says, what do you want to do? They have a very funny exchange here. The difference between Michael's plan and Jim's plan is pretty amazing. Michael's
number one idea is let's make a sign that says it's opposite day. I know. Done, solved. I know. And what I love is that Jim's ideas, they just walk in and tell Joe that they want to switch jobs, but he has to put it in language Michael will understand by saying, why don't we do it the lethal weapon way? What happens in lethal weapon? They just walk in and tell their boss what they want, right? Yes. The lethal weapon way. Let's do that. So they do. They find Joe walking her dogs outside. She really can't believe that two grown men haven't been able to figure this out. Two grown ass men. That's what she says. She gets a phone call in the middle of this exchange. She's like, fine, my God, just I don't care. Just stop meeting with me to talk about it. And here,
walk my dogs and don't ride them. Yeah, a lot of people try to ride them. I bet they do. We had a fan question from Catherine H and Denver, Colorado, who wanted to know where the lines and don't ride them. A lot of people try to ride them scripted or improvised. Guys, that was scripted. The way she delivered that was so amazing. I agree. Just perfection. When I reread this shooting draft, like everything is scripted. Like there are moments where I was like, oh, was that someone going off script? No, this was like all scripted every little moment you see. When Michael messes up Jim's hair earlier, I went to the script. I was like, maybe that was Steve just playing around. Nope, in the script. Really? Yep. It says Michael messes
up Jim's hair. Well, Andy's going to quickly make an announcement to the bullpen that he has sent an email saying, look, if you think I like you because of this Valentine's card, I'm paraphrasing, but basically, I don't like you. Okay. Yeah. It meant nothing to me. It meant nothing. Well, Kelly comes in wide open. Hey, very nice. Kelly's mad because she's like, do you not like me? I would have liked you so hard. And Andy tells Kelly there's someone else, but he won't say who. Oh, there was a deleted Andy talking head. Oh, what did it say? He said, I gave Kelly $50 and she promised to stop loving me. Okay. That's pretty great. But Aaron's happy now because it turned out Andy didn't like Kelly.
And Michael is happy as well because he's back in his office. And Aaron has set up all of his gadgets and they're going to have a little dance party. At 20 minutes, one second, Aaron activates Michael's little Casio keyboard and we hear two pieces of music. Randy Cordray said they were loop tracks that were found by our sound supervisor, Bobby Maxden. We licensed those song loops in perpetuity and it cost $3,000. Well, Dwight is just delighted that Jim is no longer manager. He rubs it in that his time as manager lasted four hours. Yeah. It's the shortest of any manager. He's holding a sheet's coffee mug, by the way. Nice. Yeah. Jim is going to take Dwight's tie and dip it in his coffee.
Oh, Jim. And the shooting draft this scene continued and you see Jim back in the annex and Toby is writing him up. What? Yes. And there's this B-roll and Jim has taken Dwight's phone and has put it in jello and put it in the fridge. And Toby says, please don't make this a habit. And Jim is just smiling. The pranks are coming back, guys. Well, everybody was very excited for this storyline. The writers spoke about how, for a while, they really liked this storyline where Jim was having to be more ambitious, he was having to be in charge, be a little serious, but they really missed the dynamic between Jim and Dwight. This was something that was sacrificed because of this storyline.
Now they were going to get to have it back. Yeah. Well, Dwight and Ryan congratulate themselves for dethroning Jim, even though they're not quite sure what it was that they did that contributed to this. You're going to see them get into the elevator and they're happy and then they get out of the elevator and they're arguing. They had to film those on two different days because the elevator doesn't really go anywhere. Right. So they got into an elevator and then it was like a total other day where they did the leaving of the elevator. Well, I loved it. I loved how it's the misdirect, right? That these two are going to go for a drink and then the doors open and they're arguing. Just one elevator ride later. It's only like a two-story building. This is a
short ride to get in a fight. The thing they're arguing about is what drink they're going to get to celebrate. Dwight says martini bars are pretentious and then Ryan says, I'm not interested in anything I have to make myself. And Dwight's like, it's beet vodka and it's delicious. I will show you. I got curious if beet vodka was a real thing. Is it? Okay. I looked this up online. This is what I found. There might be others, but I did find a vodka from Minnesota called BET and there's a line over the E, B-E-T, beet vodka. It's Minnesota's first vodka distilled from 100% sugar beats. Sugar beats. Yes. I was not able to get that vodka in time, but I also read that you can make your own beet infused vodka and I looked up the recipe and I made it. You did not. I did. You made beet
infused vodka? Explain. Okay. I found a recipe on allrecipes.com. This one is by Jonah Luck giving you a shout out Jonah. Here's the quote about this recipe. This is a full-flavored and earthy vodka that will keep you coming back. The ingredients were two pounds of beets peeled and cubed. I went to the store. I bought a lot of beets. I peeled them. My hands were red. I was trying to hide them from you the other day on our edit because my hands were so stained from peeling these beets and I cubed them and cut them in little squares on Monday. I have to stop you. What was the reaction to the people in the store when Angela came in and bought two pounds of beets? At the checkout line, the guy checking me out,
you could see everything in him. It was like you could see the vein in his forehead. He had to weigh the beets and he was like, you're buying beets? And I was like, aha. And he goes, aha. He so wanted to say something. Okay. So on Monday, I had to peel and cube the beets. It took an actual long time. And then I had to get one liter of vodka and I had to put the beets in a sealable container and pour vodka over the beets and shake it vigorously. Then I had to place the container in a cool dark place and store it for three days. But twice a day, I had to go and shake it. Oh my gosh. This is what I've been doing all week and I wanted to tell you. I brought them. I got individual little containers so we can all try my beet infused
你能看清他的一切。就像你能看到他额头上的青筋。他得称甜菜，然后他就像是，你在买甜菜？而我就像是，啊哈。他则说，啊哈。他太想说点什么了。好吧。所以星期一，我得给甜菜去皮并切成丁。这真的花了好长时间。然后我得买一升伏特加，我得把甜菜放进一个可密封的容器里，把伏特加倒在甜菜上，然后大力摇晃。接着我得把容器放在阴凉黑暗的地方存放三天。但一天两次，我都得去摇晃它。哦天哪。这就是我一整周都在做的事情，我想告诉你。我带来了。我准备了单独的小容器，这样我们都可以尝尝我泡的
vodka. I'm going to tell you I tried it this morning. It is earthy. Okay. Earthy. I documented making it all. I'll put it in stories. Now this is just, you don't do anything to the beets except cube them. You didn't have to boil them or make them soft. It's raw beet. Yes. It's raw beet. That's why I couldn't cheat and buy already because they had packages of steamed cube beets. But it's raw beets. Let's try it. This is also another nice way to say happy birthday, Sam. Oh guys, I have individual containers for you to take home. So you're taking this home. Let's try some beet infused vodka. All right guys. It looks like a container of blood. Things I never thought I would do. All right. Wait, here we go. The beet really comes through.
伏特加。我跟你们说，我今天早上尝过了。它有一种泥土的气息。好吧。泥土气息。我把制作的过程都记录下来了。我会发到快拍里。现在这只是，你对甜菜什么都不用做，除了把它切成丁。你不需要把它们煮熟或变软。这是生甜菜。是的。是生甜菜。这就是为什么我不能偷懒去买现成的，因为他们有包装好的蒸甜菜丁。但这是生甜菜。我们来尝尝吧。这也是另一种祝萨姆生日快乐的好方式。哦，伙计们，我给你们准备了单独的容器可以带回家。所以你们要把这个带回家。我们来尝尝甜菜浸泡伏特加吧。好吧，伙计们。这看起来像一盒血。有些事我从没想过我会做。好吧。等等，我们开始吧。甜菜的味道真的很浓。
Okay. Do you smell the beet? I smell the beet. It's as earthy as promised. Okay, ready? Here we go. We're going to sip it. It's exactly how I pictured it. Yeah. That's a tub of beets. It's a medicine-y. It reminds me of a medicine. Here is the thing. All you taste are beets. So the vodka could sneak up on you, but it's there. There you go guys. This is like us having to drink a shrewt farbs. Yay. What if we threw a Splendid in here? I feel like that's what it needs. I'm going to make a Bloody Mary with this and report back. Oh, there was a recipe for that, to make Bloody Marys with beet infused vodka. Oh, Sam, I have a much bigger container you can take home. Greg, thank you. Yay. Angela, this was delightful. This is really was. Thank you for
好吧。你闻到甜菜味了吗？我闻到甜菜味了。正如承诺的那样，有着浓郁的泥土气息。好吧，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。我们要小口品尝。这完全是我想象中的样子。是的。这就是一盆甜菜。有点像药味。让我想起了一种药。问题是。你尝到的全都是甜菜。所以伏特加可能会悄悄袭击你，但它就在那儿。给你，伙计们。这就像我们不得不喝苦药汤一样。耶。如果我们在这里加点思克兰迪（Splendid代糖）会怎么样？我觉得这就是它需要的。我要用这个做血腥玛丽（Bloody Mary）然后回来汇报。哦，有个食谱就是用甜菜伏特加做血腥玛丽的。哦，萨姆，我有一个更大的容器你可以带走。格雷格，谢谢你。耶。安吉拉，这太棒了。真的太棒了。谢谢你
making this. You guys drink responsibly. This was a really fun thing to do. Actually, I enjoyed it, and I feel like Dwight would be proud, guys. This is like, what's the name of those people who, like, mixologist level? Yes. Kind of business here, and. I'm excited for on the way home when I get on the train beet drunk holding a plant. You're drinking your beet vodka with your succulent. Well, you guys, that was manager and salesman. If you were keeping track of how many times the dogs went to Andy's Crutch, he had those dogs, I mean, up in there for five full scenes. Wow. That's quite a bit of time if you look at the whole episode. Well, on that note, I guess we want to say thank you to Rainn Wilson, who I reached out to you for this episode and Randy Cordray
做这个。大家要理性饮酒。这是一件非常有趣的事情。其实我很喜欢，而且我觉得德怀特会为我们骄傲的，伙计们。这就像，那些人的名字叫什么来着，比如，调酒师级别的？是的。这里有点那种生意的意思，而且。我很兴奋在回家的路上，当我坐上地铁时，喝着甜菜伏特加，手里还拿着一株植物。你正端着多肉植物喝着你的甜菜伏特加。好吧，伙计们，那是经理和推销员。如果你一直在记录狗狗们靠近安迪拐杖的次数，那些狗狗，我是说，在整整五场戏里都在那儿。哇。如果你看整集的话，这可真是相当长的一段时间。好吧，借此机会，我想我们要感谢雷恩·威尔逊，我为了这一集联系了你，还有兰迪·科德雷
and Angela Kinsey for making us fresh beet vodka. Thank you, Angela. You're welcome. You're welcome, guys. Have a great week. We love doing this podcast. Thanks for hanging out with us next week. We are going to be in New York City for our book launch. I can't believe it. I know. Are you ready? I don't think so. I don't feel ready. I don't feel ready, but I am so excited. This took three and a half years of our lives, and I'm just so happy we finally get to share it. And as my mom says, we can bless it and move it on. A couple of fun things to be on the lookout for. We are going to release a sneak peek of our audio book later this week. And then next week, in honor of our book, The Office BFFs coming out, we are doing a special episode where we answer all of your
和安吉拉·金西给我们带来了新鲜的甜菜伏特加。谢谢你，安吉拉。不客气。不客气，伙计们。祝大家有个愉快的一周。我们很喜欢做这个播客。谢谢你们下周跟我们一起闲逛。我们将在纽约市举行我们的新书发布会。我简直不敢相信。我知道。你准备好了吗？我不觉得。我觉得我没准备好。我觉得我没准备好，但我太兴奋了。这花去了我们生活的三分半时间，我只是太高兴我们终于可以分享它了。正如我妈妈所说，我们可以祝福它然后继续前进。有几件有趣的事情值得关注。我们将在本周晚些时候发布我们有声书的先导片段。然后下周，为了庆祝我们的书《办公室闺蜜》（The Office BFFs）的出版，我们将做一个特别节目，在节目中回答你们所有的
questions. See you guys. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
问题。再见，伙计们。再见。感谢收听《办公室闺蜜》。《办公室闺蜜》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行监制。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室闺蜜》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 享受一个月免费试用，请使用代码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。